[Music]
foreign
welcome back everybody attorneys are
gearing up for trial in Lata County
Idaho for quadruple murder suspect Brian
coburger but in the meantime more
allegations about the defendant's past
are coming to light coburger scheduled
to stand trial in October for the
stabbing deaths of four University of
Idaho students last November Madison
Mogan Kayla Gonzalez honor kernodle and
Ethan Chapin prosecutors tied co-worker
to the crime scene through GPS tracking
data and DNA found on a knife sheath
near one of the victims bodies at the
time the murderous co-burger was
pursuing a PhD in criminology at nearby
Washington State University before that
happened he had to complete his high
school education online after leaving
Pleasant Valley High School in
Pennsylvania a former administrator at
the high school Tanya Carmella beers
spoke about coburger's alleged history
on the Idaho Massacre podcast and she
recalled one specific incident junior
year that required an investigation
coburger was part of a vocational law
enforcement program in the school
district and several female students
reportedly filed complaints about him
according to the former administrator
several interviews were conducted with
students and co-burger regarding the
incident after the investigation School
staff reportedly moved him to a
different vocational program at the end
of the school year co-berger decided not
to return while the basis of the
allegations were in disclosed Carmella
beers said on the podcast quote what had
him removed from the program when I look
back on it now makes sense
Brian interesting facts as we're always
trying to understand the back story to
Brian Coburg or what a potential motive
could be is any of that going to come
into trial though it is a very very very
slim chance that it does and I know that
we had talked about this before how you
had looked up the Idaho law and there
has to be some sort of notice as to
whether or not the prosecution wants to
use it for the very specific aspect of
the motive I don't think it's going to
come in that way because we don't even
know the facts of this fully but let's
let's imagine the worst maybe he gets
violent against women maybe he feels
slighted by them and does something
violent towards them you know what I
know he didn't do telling those women
kill them and so if you're going to try
to compare yelling or some sort of
violent Outburst to stabbing for women
uh almost over a decade ago I think it
gets really hard where I do think it
could come in is if he takes the Stanley
he says I would never be violent to
women I would never raise my voice I
would never do this then the prosecution
gets to impeach him and say oh you said
never let me tell you about what you did
in high school so that I think it's a
very dangerous situation where we could
potentially open the door real quick
that could be reveal field so even
though it's private right now if he
brings it into issue that could be
revealed in a court of law yeah it could
it would be good for impeachment they I
mean they have to have it on on the
ready though
to think right whether or not submitted
or not for our purposes we're trying to
understand if he did this why he did
this there's so much reporting about his
interaction with women and what he's
been up to you think this goes to motive
at all I definitely think it goes to
motive but remember he killed three
women and one man so it's really odd
that these you know I guess
allegations about what he did earlier
all involve women and now he's killed
three women and a man boyfriend
but yes but the point is it's a guy and
you know it's interesting why he killed
these people because I think everybody
does want to know what could have you
know instigated this whole thing did he
see them somewhere in a restaurant did
he have a past where he you know had
negative interactions with women it's
very odd that so far there is nothing
explaining why this stranger
theoretically would come in and kill
four people in the middle of the night
and by the way not kill these other
people who were in the building so I
think if we could come with some sort of
explanation it's going to satisfy you
know obviously if it gets introduced
into trial it'll satisfy the jury but
it'll satisfy the public as well and
there's also a real possibility the
straw goes on we mean and if he's
convicted we may never know why he
actually did this but we're not a theory
and welcome back to Long Prime daily
everybody the young woman accused of
killing her newborn in a hospital
bathroom was in a New Mexico courtroom
on Tuesday several motions were filed
with the court Alexi Treviso went to the
hospital with back pain and says she
didn't know that she was pregnant police
body cam video shows a reaction
afterwards with her mother
Lexi I told you about this
but if I just asked you baby to tell me
the troubles
it was not surprised
what did you do to it okay stop right
here
well an autopsy ruled the baby's death a
homicide apparently dying from a lack of
oxygen trevisa was charged with first
degree murder and tampering with
evidence she's pleaded not guilty her
defense team argues that it's the
hospital's fault the baby died because
of the medication they gave traviso for
her pain now during the hearing on
Tuesday multiple motions were addressed
they included requests for a change of
venue a motion to suppress any
information protected under HIPAA a
request to depose a forensic
toxicologist on video and a motion to
change the conditions of a release
pre-trial so that she can attend college
in the fall
Treviso is set to go to trial in October
let's break all this down so Brian fence
files a number of different motions here
uh one was for suppressing statements
about something I don't get the strike
called Pina V Espinoza that case what
are they talking about yeah so the
suppression is as of for HIPAA issues as
well as in lack of Miranda and the
defense is saying is like all the rest
of us you can't share someone's personal
medical information similar to like that
of the Miranda warnings you can't use
those facts or those statements against
a person unless you properly mirandize
them and they waive that right however
like with Miranda just as if
um in HIPAA the issue here is probably
the mother if there's a third party
there during HIPAA or even
privileged information you break that
privilege so officers can stand there as
you're talking to your mother explaining
how you committed a crime or or threw
away your baby and it works the other
exception as well is
the hospital can give up your
information if they believe a crime
occurred and they saw enough of the
facts there to suggest that there's a
potential homicide and they can relay
that to officers now the Pina case
that's just about in-camera review they
want the judge to look at this privately
and then decide whether or not this
information should go to the prosecutor
or should remain suppressed meaning
never make it to trial those are
important issues um but Terry my
understanding is you feel quite
passionately about the issue regarding
the release because you heard me say
that it has to do with whether or not
she could attend college what's your
feeling on her being able to be released
to those conditions being changed so
right now the current conditions are she
cannot attend the same school or talk to
or be around her boyfriend the boyfriend
who theoretically caused her pregnancy
and I think the Judge is doing that
because he doesn't want them to talk to
each other in case there's a case along
the line as far as her child is
concerned or perhaps he thinks and this
is one of the arguments that was made in
the motion papers that the two of them
together may have conspired now I think
there is something inherently wrong with
saying you can't talk to your boyfriend
you can't go to college if she's out and
she's doing other things they're very
limited release conditions why wouldn't
you be able to go to the college where
she was accepted why wouldn't she be
able to talk to her boyfriend it's as
though the judge is saying look I don't
want you talking to this guy because he
also is involved in this crime and
there's no evidence to that effect so I
just think telling her she can't have a
boyfriend that she wants is going Way
Beyond something that a judge can order
okay these are important questions as
this case progresses forward in the
legal system
and we're finishing Today's Show with a
shocking new lawsuit from the NBA the
New York Knicks are suing members of the
Toronto Raptors for allegedly spying on
their team the lawsuit is filed in
Manhattan federal court on Monday the
New York basketball team accuses a
former video director Ike azotam of
illegally obtaining and sharing
proprietary carry information with the
canada-based Raptors according to the
lawsuit that information included
scouting reports play frequency reports
a prep book and a third party licensed
software azotam worked with the Knicks
for almost three years before informing
the team in July that he was leaving to
work for the Raptors around that time
the Knicks claimed that the Raptors new
head coach darco ryakovich was a first
timer in the NBA and their staff needed
guidance on management that's when they
allegedly quote recruited and used
azotam to serve as a mole within the Nix
organization to convey information to
the Raptors defendants Knicks are asking
for a permanent injunction on the
Raptors along with an undisclosed amount
of Damages for claims including breach
of contract misappropriation of Trade
Secrets conversion unfair competition
and unjust enrichment so what do the
Knicks need to prove that this happened
Terry well I think they have an
excellent case in fact it's a slam dunk
if you ask me
and I say that because look all the
evidence is there they have emails lined
up saying here's the information here's
how they work with other teams here's
their playbook that is a trade secret
that's proprietary information and so
that cause of action is definitely going
to Prevail I think they have a breach of
contract claim against azatam and he had
an employment agreement and it said
confidential information must be kept
confidential he breached that they have
a tortious interference of contract by
the Toronto Raptors and they have a good
claim for that as well because what
they're saying is look you interfered
with the contract that we had with
azatam so I think for those three main
areas and the others that you mentioned
also the unjust enrichment they have a
really good case the facts are with them
seems like a layup for the Knicks
no but seems like a layup right in the
sense like it seems like a pretty good
case for them you I'm going to give you
the chance to defend you're Canadian my
Homer native Market you're the home in
native land what could a defense be I
see your layup I see your slam dunk I'm
gonna step back behind the arc and watch
this shot okay I think for the most part
what it really is about indemnifying the
people
um if you could take isamotam and say
Hey you are this rogue agent you did all
of this on your own because from what
I'm seeing he's got emails from his old
Nick's uh email address sending it to
his new Toronto Raptors one the thing
that I'm missing out is the mole aspect
who is sending him to go and do this and
at first I thought there was no way my
Raptors are looking at what the Knicks
are doing because no one really cares
but it's not the information about the
Knicks themselves it's about their
propriety information about other teams
so it made more sense to me but if you
could show that this was not done by the
direction of any one of the Raptors but
this was just a rogue agent I think the
Raptors walk away from this pretty safe
and as the time goes down on his own
real quick is that a good defense no I
don't think so because I think they have
communications between azotem and
between the Raptors saying you know this
information we need it give it to me you
know so I think they're all involved
here all right this debate is going into
overtime that's my last one uh Brian
Terry thanks for jumping in on this
thanks for joining us here on Long crime
daily everybody we're going to see you
next time as we discuss Justice in
America